[Music]
thank you
all right okay I'm the homelander I'm I
am homelander
as a superhero sometimes you have to do
things so
why did I do it I did it because it's
the right thing to do quite simply I did
it because it's the right thing to do
there you go everybody loves you because
you're perfect
firefighters are the real heroes you got
five firefighters
you guys are the real heroes
you oh God teachers teacher teachers
teachers teachers are the custodians of
our youth they are the real
Heroes you do nothing you think you can
do what I do
do it
nobody can do what I do
I'm the homelander I'm the homelander
and I can do whatever the [__] I want
foreign
[Music]